trapped in my body i have the career
look now i look completely korean
if you didn't know who i was you would
just think i was a korean person
be happy with who you are it's as simple
as that if you're not happy with how you
look
you are never going to be happy with
what you become wow yeah
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu alaikum brothers and sisters
and dear friends hope you guys are one
inshallah
uh today we're going to be watching a
video with uh sean smarty janna how you
doing
let's watch the video
so in this video we have an individual
who says
being korean now it's pronounced korean
yes so korean so i wanted to know what
this is about
so let's go here we go so um
they do like from the does she look
i don't know if he or she by the way is
it do they look
um korean i mean
if i say yes and then i give my proof
i'm going to be classed as a racist
if i say no then i'm going to be a liar
oh you don't want to bother let's see
what she
or he i don't know what this thing is
has to say are we getting yeah
hey guys i just want to take this chance
to um
you know come out today something that's
been like
on my mind for a long time and i've been
very confused about how i identify i've
been very very confused and you know
i've seen a lot of other people online
accent british
but i'm curious what's going on i'll be
confused
and shared their story about how they
identify their gender their pronouns etc
so you know i've taken courage from
these incredibly brave
people and it is pride month at the
moment so you know i thought this was
the best time to do it
um you know and i had a voice and
strength the lgbtq plus i
community um so i am going to come out
today and say that i've been
transitioning
i've been very unhappy with who i am
deep down
um for the last eight years and i've
been like 18 plastic surgeries now
i've just had a facelift um temple lift
an eye surgery or canthoplasty
and my teeth as well just these are just
part of my transition
um i'm feeling really good on for the
first time in my life i feel beautiful
you know i'm looking in the mirror
18 plastic surgeries and this is
all linked to not feeling happy
do you not think sometimes people should
just take that time out and try to find
who they are what they want and also
bear in mind that they are influenced by
their society
so how can i make a massive decision to
have 18 surgeries
to change i don't know about gender or
her
cultural background identity based on
something because i
feel ugly that could be a moment thing
that could be a thing where
you can come up with a bro when i was
young i had moments where i thought i
was like really unattractive
or stuff like that because of my society
how they were made to feel because what
what was attractiveness you get it
because of that definition
now because of what society is the
burden that is put on me
how can i make such a massive life
decision that i change my
whole body my face um i don't know
i just find it like find yourself before
because your
process could be um well you're trying
to pollute it yeah what you're trying to
say
is don't act upon impulse
yeah impulse yeah that's pretty much
but i hope people can respect my
decision it's a very tough
decision to come out this way but i am
coming out
as non-binary um i don't feel i identify
as male or female i just feel like
i'm just in the middle um and my
pronouns are they
them korean jimin because i know a lot
of people korean jimin
she says i feel like well you're feeling
your feelings can change what was the
jimin about what is this
i don't know i think it's some kind of a
korean name okay so
saying that you feel like that but those
feelings can change our feelings change
quite often
yeah daily i would say yeah so does that
mean that now i feel
very antagonistic towards you i feel
like bringing you exactly
not i feel like that all the time
against you um
but if i was to move according to my
feelings
my gosh i would probably look like a
dinosaur because
you know no because i feel like this now
i feel like that now
what you meant by that i don't know and
i would make a lot of transitions
i do feel korean i don't identify as
british so please don't
um refer to me any media or anyone
online as british because i i identify
as korean that's just my culture that's
my home country
that's exactly how that's my whole
country that's my culture that's a lie
yeah well it is you're not you're
british she's saying basically but maybe
she
broke it's like they've moved bro it's
as good as no no come on
living there no no you can move there no
no but the thing is even if you move
there
your home country is britain you're
british your home is where you hang your
hat isn't it
okay whatever then and then this is my
house your house is my house then
because
so the thing is the thing here is that
you are telling yourself a massive lie
but biological biologically you're lying
no i'm not lying no
don't you think the biological she's
like lying to herself not only that
culturally
she's identifying as something that
she's not she thinks or she wants to be
the thing is bro when you discard a
faith
when you discard god when you discard
the yardstick
that has helped humanity for millennia
and then you look towards what you're
feeling
feelings are very dangerous they vary
like you said based upon where you're
living
based upon your current mood yes based
upon the movies and the music you're
listening to
based upon your current circumstance if
you're with a partner if you're not with
a partner
if you're watching certain movies you're
playing certain games like people
some people they're very fascinated by
the italian culture by the japanese
culture
some people are very fascinated with
indian culture
or western culture so it totally depends
and to make life and body altering
decisions
based upon like you said impulse that's
a very fragile life
and it's a very it's a life which is
filled with
uncertainty filled with
um just there's no joy there's no
contentment
because i mean one week i'm feeling this
way and i make
18 surgeries the next week i may regret
it and then there's no way back
exactly now people can choose that
culturally to dress up in a certain way
etc they might like you know if they
listen to rap you know it's fine looking
a certain way you act a certain way
but to start then changing your body to
look
like something you're not it's strange
well let's carry on i don't know
yeah i mean it's strange i would maybe
elaborate on that and say it's
it's it's it's risky and irreversible
yes
it's a irreversible decision yeah
um
not only that i just i know it's a
little bit confusing for some people
nobody's ever come out as jimin or
korean but
um this is something that you guys know
if you've followed my journey for the
last eight years i've really struggled
with
identity issues with who i am
you know with who i am it's a very tough
one so
i finally had the courage i've undergone
my
um racial uh
i can't think of the words transitional
surgery you know
i've transitioned to a non-binary person
they them korean gym in and i finally
have the korean look so i'm actually
really happy
um but i just want to say to people you
know i get so many cool comments online
i just want people to be able to respect
my decision
and don't be you know non-binary phobic
or anything just please
respect that this is how i feel this is
a very personal decision
and i've been inspired by the courage of
other people other young people who have
come out and
come out as non-binary will come out in
a different way and that's really going
to give me the courage
because i think if they can do it so can
i so as it's uh
pride month i just wanted to put this
out there i've been very entrapped in my
body
for so long and you know i identified
the korean culture
i've lived in korea i speak the language
i have the korean look now i look
completely korean
if you didn't know who i was you would
just think i was a korean person
you know even those words you see how
much time she repeated korean or he
what do you even they yeah they look at
this
as far as i don't know if i think it's a
he but just transgendered into a [ __ ] or
non-binary
yeah i'm sorry i'm just going to say he
yeah all right
yeah the thing is how many times this
person said korean and no i look korean
and now
like it's it's as if the insecurity is
so high
like no no i look korean now you can't
deny it now i'm a korean
like who are you proving what to and
this goes back to submitting your will
to allah almighty
be happy with who you are it's as simple
as that if you're not happy with how you
look
you are never going to be happy with
what you become
wow yeah yes if you're not happy with
what you look like they think that
they're happy
that's the thing no but that's it
no no they haven't so i think bro it's
just submitting your will to allah
and accept it and if you don't and you
go for transition i think malcolm x
they think they're happy if you don't
stand for something brother
which is yourself yeah in the context of
it like your deen
but happy with contentment you will fall
for anything and this is what's
happening
well the thing is that's it it was first
transgender to change their their gender
then it's their whole culture then it's
their whole country but they're happy
well if that is happiness then i prefer
to be unhappy
any last words yeah i think the point
is that's how they feel at this moment
in time but because
their entire world view is now based
upon feelings
feelings we know are transient and
they're constantly
evolving and metamorphosizing and
changing
yes so uh don't don't do that yeah
exactly look
the she this person can change do
whatever they like but the point here is
this
it's dealing with mental illness you
know dealing with it if it's a problem
in security we need to see what factors
play a role in making us making
decisions
and if it's external sources then the
problem is there not within ourselves
then we can't take that decision to
change our thought process and our body
and our whole way of life and deny our
reality biologically even man like it's
undeniable fact
to deny that and don't call me british
but anyways look like i said this person
i
they might be going through something i
don't want them to watch this and feel
depressed if you feel like that look
that's your choice you can do whatever
you like
but genuinely finding your purpose in
god and serving him is the greatest
contentment that you can get and that's
all
how we're all programmed and i would
encourage you to read the quran
um and find your contentment uh via
worshiping the creator
rather than serving many creators on
this earth which are false creators of
course
um and yeah that's it until next time
sisters hope you guys enjoyed this if
you know any similar videos or something
all those lines you want
us to react to send it to us goodbye